on va passer donc à notre thème suivant
le thème suivant il est question des
campus américains alors le figaro a
publié c'est un sujet pour vous au génie
le figaro a publié cette semaine une
interview d'un avocat sur le
politiquement correct dans les facs
américaines
son nom c'est greg loukianov alors c'est
vous qui avez réalisé cette interview au
génie j'essaye de la résumer rapidement
il est question de l'apparition d'une
nouvelle culture sur les campus
américains culture dont le but est de
purger les cours les débats de toute
idée mots ou sujets susceptibles
d'offenser les étudiants étudiants
étudiantes devrais je peux te dire ce
qui revient à censurer tout ce qui peut
heurter alors par exemple on ne peut
plus dire à quelqu'un on devrait plus
dire à quelqu'un qu'il parle par exemple
très bien anglais parce que cela
sous-entend qu'il n'est pas inactif
américain qui n'est pas un vrai
américain c'est à peu près ça pour
essayer de donner un exemple concret est
ce que ça peut donner
je vous donne pas tout de suite la
parole au génie parce que change est
intarissable sur le sujet
renée fregosi fregosi ça vous choque
vous qui êtes féministe cette tendance
du politiquement correct
ah oui absolument parce que c'est pas du
tout ma conception du féminisme c'est
pas un féminisme puritains que je
défends depuis que je suis tout jeune
c'est un féminisme de la libération
sexuelle de la liberté des moeurs et de
la libre pensée de la libre disposition
de son corps ce qui est pas du tout le
cas
à mon sens des néo féministes comme
jeudi
mais vous savez ces précieuses et que
sait faire des eaux féministe la saison
pas du tout ce qu'on l'aimé mais ce
politiquement correct il fait pas
seulement aux états unis hélas il est
aussi dans les universités françaises se
pourrait qu'elle faisait quelques
abeilles par exemple des exemples qui me
touchent directement par exemple vous
n'avez pas le droit de dire que personne
le
le leader populiste argentin des années
50 une spécialiste a été la porte
d'entrée des nazis après la deuxième
guerre mondiale
mon article eh bien je n'ai pas pu le
passer dans la revue de mon université
il va paraître prochainement aux temps
modernes mais parce que lanzmann juste
avant de mourir là lui a plu et donc il
sera publié mais parce que je n'ai pas
le droit d'attaquer le péronisme parce
que je fais des liens aussi avec le
péronisme d'aujourd'hui par exemple mais
c'est un débat les hétéros mais mais
mais mais mais sinon aux blessés du
gauche rythme avant et en haoussa c'est
à dire que en tous les cas il ya des
thèmes qui sont un terreau dabou qui
sont à bout mais ça on le sait bien il
ya le thème de l'immigration c'est tabou
le mais là on parle plus me semble il ya
des demandes sur les co 2 sur wii mais
ça c'était à mon avis et on n'est même
pas dans le contenu des études on est
dans le vivre ensemble
oui mais c'est aussi les mots qu'on
emploie voyez moi quand je je parle de
la traite négrière
il faut que j'explique que c'est un
concept que je ne traite pas les noirs
de [ __ ] la traiterait les grillons
langage concept et je dois alors
expliqué je vous donne ma part
expliquez-nous un peu plus ce qu'il en
ressort
et en quoi ça peut aller non alors en
fait le livre de monsieur week-end donc
lui qui lui est un avocat qui n'est pas
un universitaire et qu'un avocat
spécialiste de la défense du premier
amendement sur la liberté d'expression
notamment sur les campus qui défend les
professeurs qui sont attaquées ou les
étudiants qui sont attaqués au nom de
cette défense qui est très importante
aux états unis la liberté d'expression
et il explique une nouvelle censure
émergent qui ne provient pas de l'état
où l'administration mais des étudiants
eux-mêmes et finalement qui émerge par
le bakoye du des campus et ils appellent
ça de codling of the american pie
il reprend le titre dans
ça va mais ça veut dire le chouchoutage
de l'esprit américain et comment fait on
essaie d'évacuer tout vexations possible
toute manière d'être au fond c est ce
que ça implique mosson est en fait c'est
spécieuse par exemple et on peut appeler
c'est un endroit où un étudiant sera
entre guillemets c'est quand sécurité
certain d'être en sécurité mais voilà il
sait pas et c'est plus la sécurité
physique c'est la sécurité même mental
et moral et intégré sera pas voilà et
donc les belles et par exemple les
professeurs suivre des formations pour
avoir le droit de coller sur leur bureau
une étiquette saïx ps il ya également ce
qu'on appelle les traders warning donc
ces messages avertissant au début des
cours par exemple quand on a étudié par
exemple un négrier regarder on va parler
de colonisation attention on va enlever
être question de viol dans ce court et
c'est donc une espèce de raie du est
derrière lui c'est le spectre est bien
c'est que ce qui est dangereux c'est
qu'à une médicalisation de la liberté
d'expression et des ans finalement
c'était la fameuse expression les mots
tus l'idée que finalement les mots la
pensée pourrait faire souffrir
psychiquement des élèves parce qu'ils
ont traumatisés parce qu'ils entendent
des choses relève l'aïe dit vraiment une
dérive parce que non seulement c'est
faux mais en fait il est lui-même dit
que il a fait une corrélation avec les
dépressions voilà lui lui-même dit que
il est suivi par une thérapie pourrons
pour dépasser celle des problèmes
dépressifs
d'ailleurs il le dit lui même il dit
mais c'est sa reine ont pas parlé et
quand on a des problèmes c'est parce il
a prôné un peu vrai y aller sur l'uss
plus la plus vraie solution quand on a
été traumatisé c'est ne jamais plus
jamais reparlé du trauma sous peine
d'être servette ça il dit que ça sert à
ça renforce les traumatismes au lieu de
les évacuer
puisqu'on refuse d'en parler ça devient
tabou et c est dit que sur les campus
américains le taux de
deux suisses ses envies de suicide a
énormément augmenté que les cellules
psychologiques ont augmenté donc ça crée
un mal-être sur la santé mentale des
étudiants qui est préoccupant plutôt que
justement car donner à des outils de
résilience ou de pain manière de voilà
de rebondir on les encourage dans ce
trauma et donc au delà ça c'est aussi
une perte de la liberté d'expression
c'est celle renée fregosi nous disait
c'est déjà le cas en france
vous avez aussi l'idée que ça peut
arriver très vite et nous envahir on est
quand même dans des cultures assez
différente mais c'est vrai que en fait
oui il ya une espèce de des sujets comme
dans toute société des sujets qui sont
difficiles à aborder
voilà et aujourd'hui c'est plus une
censure effectivement qui vient
forcément je pense duo de corps institué
deux voilà qu'on pouvait voir autrefois
des autorités morales de l'église du
parti communiste de ceci de cela il ya
plus ces autorités morales de ses c'est
le corps qui gênait un peu un peu ça par
peur de froisser et ou en tout cas moi
je
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il faut
apprendre à être au fond c'est dans la
vie ce parce que sinon il n'ya pas y a
pas de débat possible à la discussion si
on supporte que des gens qui ont
exactement les mêmes du dégoût je ne
vois pas comment la vie est tout
simplement même possible parce qu'enfin
pour la rue ce n'est pas aux exercices
de l'escroquer c'est aussi le mental la
lumière de l'actuelle embauche aussi des
mouvances est là
et la contradiction s'explique aussi
nokia nok et qui est intéressant c'est
le remplacement aussi de l'aspiration à
l'universel qui était au coeur de
déshumanité par une espèce de pensée
tribale où chacun pense à ses
souffrances et selon son passé de
victimes c'est à dire les femmes les
femmes penser à se penser en tant que
victime du patriarcale et les noirs en
tant que victimes de l'esclavagé etc etc
et chacun est dans sa petite case et
finalement on aboutit à la perte de
l'universel qui paiement fondement d
humanité de notamment les études de
lettres ou de philosophie qui est quand
même une idée de sortir de son
individualité pour aspirer à une
condition humaine commune et ça c'est si
on a eu très dangereux alors je ne fais
pas de sexisme je vous donne la parole
alexandre simplement quelques réponses à
notre question twitter d'abord la
réponse elle même global craignez-vous
une importation en france du
politiquement correct venue des états
unis
vous êtes deux tiers est le craindre à
dire oui c'est une crainte citoyens
payeurs nous dit le politiquement
correct est une invitation au mensonge
c'est cet intéressant comme idée
d'ailleurs on y reviendra nicole ce
politiquement correct devient
insupportable on vit maintenant
pardonnez moi j'ai un petit problème tu
as envie maintenant dans un monde où on
ne peut plus rien dire
blueberry cake c'est son surnom le
politiquement correct vient du fait
qu'on a fait passer les minorités au
dessus de la majorité dans l'ordre des
priorités politiques maurice ça fait des
décennies qu'on vit ce politiquement
correct on y est habitués et nicole
quand seuls les minorités peuvent
s'exprimer
où est la démocratie et la liberté
d'expression qui est pourtant dans les
droits de l'homme
alexandre vous avez la parole la
minorité masculine va s'exprimer j'ai
failli me sentir discriminés
non c'est compliqué comme problème les
ce que ça vient ça vient de loin le
sentiment que ça donne comme ça moi je
suis pas un expert du sujet donc se
montrer prudents de compétence là dessus
mais gentiment que ça donne c'est qu'en
fait c'est un peu cette espèce de
vengeance du faible dire que quelque
part ces espèces de monter en pression
de deux courants identitaires
communautaires qui viennent à un moment
donné faire irruption comme ça et qui au
nom d'une d'une problématique d'une
forme d'injustice d'une d'un ressenti de
quelque chose et tout d'un coup c'est
spes de faiblesse devient une force
contre 1 contre un système un moyen de
pression et c'est vrai qu'avec un plus
un langage utilisé qui est difficilement
contestable par ce qui veut dire et
redire il faut prendre de la distance et
votre n'êtes pas raisonnable enfin
soyons sérieux c'est pratiquement
impossible de serrer site r déjà je
crois un exemple sur un sur un des gens
tous les débats télévisés pu faire où il
y avait des pâtes que des féministes
comme vous mais parfois certaines
féministes un peu agressive ou
globalement en tant que mâle blanc voilà
je vais dire hétérosexuels mais bon
c'est pas le sujet mais je n'avais pas
le droit de parler quoi donc on est on
est tout d'un coup enfermé dans un rôle
avec une impossibilité à faire valoir un
point de vue qui augmentera très
inclusif et très engagée sur mais je
suis pas audible voilà donc cette espèce
de dérive la salm un peu le sentiment
comme ça il ya la vengeance du faible
qui dit voilà moi je suis dans ma
catégorie et c'est pas grave je suis pas
représentatif et je vais y aller ça
c'est un vrai sujet de fond qu'il faudra
essayer de voir abordés et ça a été très
bien décrit a longtemps je pense par
exemple aux bouquins dans la main qu'en
2003 qui parlait de la tire unis
s'étaient pas la thyroïde est
susceptible comme l'avait titre à une
rente hebdomadaire ya quelques semaines
c'était la tyrannie des minorités ils
ont été également voilà cette espèce de
capacité de quelques-uns vraiment au nom
d'une cause totalement exclusive est
particulière à tout d'un coup faire un
flux et les choses et ça c'est un sujet
qu'on sait aujourd'hui qu'on sait pas
appréhendé est ce que c'est vrai que
c'est la tyrannie du politiquement
correct avec les débats qu'on peut pas
ouvrir
on l'a vu je prends je suis fidèle et là
dessus sur les problématiques de
d'immigration d'islam
il a fallu attendre que le sang coule
beaucoup pour que tout d'un coup on
puisse dire des choses qui ne vous
assimile pas au front national
et encore ça va un peu mieux pour
répondre parce que ce que notre
internaute qui dit c'est une invitation
mensonge
oui c'est un mensonge puisque le royaume
en grec c'est finalement de refuser de
nommer les choses parce qu'on estime que
nommer les choses va conduire à une
forme de revanche des répercussions
terribles sur le réel et je pense qu'il
ya là on est vraiment le coeur du sujet
c'est de dire qu'il ya un continuum
entre les violences verbales et les
violences physiques qui s'en prennent
aux individus et je crois que là c'est
le même sujet sur le féminisme c'est à
dire de dire que c'est la même chose de
dire une parole agressif c'est la même
chose qu'un acte je pense qu'il faut et
on a un problème de hiérarchie en disant
que non la parole ce n'est pas
l'appareil que l'acte et dire des choses
c'est parfaite ne mène pas forcément à
des actions et en espèces de traumatisme
comme ça en dix ans finalement c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs confié mais plein de
limites à la liberté d'expression dans
l'espace public ça en dix ans finalement
il ya ce qu'on appelle l'incitation à la
haine par exemple qui est très utilisé
en disant voilà c'est à dire les choses
ça va forcément conduire des gens à se
conduire de façon agressive et c'est moi
je crois que parfois c'est complètement
décor et décorrélés il ya des gens
extrêmement violent qui parle
extrêmement bien et c est l inverse est
possible aussi donc
et je crois que si je continue à me l'a
entre toutes les violences nous empêche
d'appréhender vraiment le réel alors
pour revenir dans des choses un peu très
concrètes
il ya un autre article était celui de
dans le figaro magazine le week-end
dernier
ce livre qui est faite qu'il était
innocent soeur gérald smith qui vit en
caroline du nord et qui décrit un peu le
papier titré quand l'amérique devient
folle alors par exemple ces histoires je
crois que vous y fait aussi allusion au
génie
des recours à des contrôles et sparadrap
la couleur des sparadraps pour dire
qu'ils sont pas adaptés à la couleur de
peau et ce qu'il faut un sourire et ce
qu'il faut parce qu'en france comprendre
on aboutit à un paradoxe qui est comme
il faut être sauf qu'il faut pas faire
de mal en fait on en arrive à des
rapports extrêmement violent on vous
interdit très violemment y compris
physiquement parfois on vous interdit de
parler d'abord des effectivement le réel
de dire les choses telles qu'elles sont
objectives najjar disent qu'ils trouvent
une phrase un paradoxe de cette douceur
qui est prôné au nom de voilà de la
protection des victimes et en fait on
nous agresse nous on nous empêche de
parler on fait la phrase que si ce genre
dit smith qui n'est pas utile de la
phrase brandi tout de suite c'est stop
hiaumet qu'il n'y ait fait ça tout de
suite je pense que c'est très très grave
parce que je pense que trump est le
résultat de sa ca le trump et la némésis
du comme les difficult road très bien et
la némésis du politiquement correct aux
etats unis c'est à dire c'est les gens
qui on a eu tellement ras-le-bol qu'on
parle des toilettes
transsexuels etc il en parlait beaucoup
dans ses meetings en trinquant le
féminisme radical du ca et le résultat
c'est trump c'est à dire le contraire du
politiquement correct un type qui dit en
a marre moi je vais vous dire la vérité
parce que les autres ne veulent pas dire
je vais vous dire tout ce que les autres
refusent de dire et quand on a trop
politiquement correct on aboutit à 30
dont moi je dis attention mais chez nous
c'est que si on importe le politiquement
correct des états unis on va apporter
aussi son résultat et la vengeance du
politiquement correct qui sera un espèce
de trump qui nous dire ah bah voilà moi
je vais dire la vérité et tous acquis
s'embarrassera plus du tout de former de
futurs électeurs
et moi je sentais très dangereux nous
voilà les faits lui c'est le grand verre
dépoli y adhèrent dix ans ils font le
coup fait non à ce que dirait c'est que
j'ai l'impression que ça va comme idée
c'est que s'amorçait les normands la
société sert chaque année dans une case
et même l'homme blanc finalement il ya
dans une case enfin il vient aussi
victime c'est aussi ça va avec la
victimisation qui est assez
insupportable de tout eh oui ça
encourage mensonge par exemple sur
l'histoire vous pouvez le voir tout le
temps chaque minorité ou les noirs ou
les arabes ecsta à son pan d'histoire et
le but n'est pas d'avoir d'aller vers la
justesse et l'analyse la plus pondéré la
plus honnête des faits énoncés de ces
d'être victime n'a plus de victimes
possible tout est trompé je pense et ça
compte ça conforte chacun en fait dans
sa faiblesse en fait la falaise devient
un projet or c'est pas un projet il faut
dépasser ses faiblesses l'on a tous
fièrement il faut vivre avec les autres
et quelque part il faut être un peu plus
fort il faut voilà il faut quitte à se
faire mal elle est allée au delà et je
pense qu'on peut pas encourager
s'agirait en tout cas c'est une tendance
de société qui si elle s'installait chez
nous déjà qu'elle est un peu là qu'on a
du mal à voir tous les débats ce serait
vraiment très près à main il
préjudiciable pour les prochaines
générations
il ya un autre aspect fort aussi il a
beaucoup de mal à le transmettre aux
jeunes ils n'ont jamais entendu qu'il
faut faire des exercices il faut
travailler et il faut prendre du plaisir
lassé voilà le chouchoutage il faut pas
les mêler orthez malheur c'est terrible
parce que on aboutit effectivement au
résultat inverse agents oui je pense que
la première adversité reaser et vous
écroulez cessa de risque
à pâques est le 21e cette fois pas de
cadeau donc autant être il ya un autre
aspect c'est celui de la d'aussi de la
discrimination positive
un tribune ce matin dans le figaro sur
le procès qui est fait toujours harvard
contre eux harvard par des étudiants
américains d'origine asiatique qui
disent les tout ce qui est une
discrimination positive quotas dans les
universités en fait on est discriminée
parce que compte tenu de nos résultats
on devrait avoir plus de chance et de
d'entrée dans les universités
or on et discriminés par rapport aux aux
américains d'origine hispanique ou ou
noirs américains c'est on le voit à
l'écran hmmm l'étude a été poussé assez
loin puisqu'ils disent qu'ils ont 25% de
chances d'être admis à vars alors qu'à
compétences égales il devra en avoir 35
% s'ils étaient blancs 75% s'il était
paniqué 95% s'il était noir dépensé à
une étude de cas les faits le le
sociologue gérald bronner sur la fait la
différence
enfin à quel point les discours pouvait
influencer selon les milieux les
les enfants d'immigrés par l'ampli
disais que en effet les enfants issus de
communautés asiatiques réussi c'est
beaucoup mieux à l'école que les enfants
issus de communautés par exemple arabo
musulmane il faisait parce qu'il y avait
un discours justement victimaire dans
certaines communautés qui encouragé
certains enfants a finalement à ne pas
travailler parce que c'est souvent la
lettone des tests et un racisme d'état
la société ne veut pas de nous nous
conte
n'est pas encouragée dans les dents de
peindre la communauté asiatique y avait
un discours beaucoup plus sur l'effort
sur l'idée de réussite mérite était donc
ils disaient voilà en fait c'est aussi
une question discours milieux sociaux
équivalents même avec même problème de
déracinement de l'immigration et c'est
certain ils réussissent même tout parce
qu'un discours qui les portent vers la
réussite
et alors qu'un autre discours que les
entretiens dans la victimisation et
dévoila il faut faire attention au cul
pour clore le débat aucune vertu
finalement à trouver à cette politique
qui est de longue date maintenant aux
états unis de discrimination positive
la positive pour les femmes par exemple
moi je me souviens là tous les débats
autour des quotas dans le parti
socialiste c'est vrai c'est c'est
complexe parce que si à un moment donné
vous mettez pas de quotas vous savez à
deux faces du tout rien ne se passe mais
ça doit être des mesures transitoires
il faut effectivement pas que ça
devienne un principe comme la parité
pour moi la parité c'est absurde parce
que à certains moments pourquoi pas
mettre un quota de 75% même de femmes
allez hop pendant trois ans on va mettre
75 % pour rééquilibrer mais après on
s'arrête mais ça n'est il faut pas eu
essentialiser justement ça c'est une
mesure technique mais de façon très
transitoire assumer pas mais mais pour
les hommes et les femmes par exemple
mais alors si on rentrait dans les
produits par exemple et là c'est mon
avis en fait ce serait beaucoup plus les
voyages en temps des sna grain que la
loi qui est et qui m'a date maintenant
d'une dizaine d'années me semble-t-il
guy astic tu sais quoi quasiment 40% de
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration
eh ben on est un pays ou alors pour le
coup on a décollé bien nous sur les
concentrations des grandes entreprises
enfin aller vite sur ce sujet prospects
la loi donc si on la savait pas loin on
n'aurait pas respecté c'est très bien on
éléments il faut on a les meilleurs en
europe
le problème c'est qui encore un très
grand décalage par rapport au comex
comité direction et que le législateur
est ce sentiment va peut-être falloir
s'en occuper ce qui pour le coup serait
catastrophique parce qu'une consécration
c'est une chose et un comité direction
qui est fondée par des formes et
paraissait
ces espèces et l'expérience opération
qui compte et là vous n'allez pas la
fabrique et on va pas la force et on a
vu dans la fonction publique ce que ça
veut dire parfois très remonté trop vite
un solide aux gens pour occuper le poste
en tant que femme
il ya eu quelques catastrophes donc et y
compris dans la hotte faut aux
entreprises françaises avec parfois
certains postes tenus par des femmes qui
n'ont pas été pas bien créé par une
console nucléaire on avait compris